la courbe monte toujours plus haut en
italie la barre des 4000 morts vient
d'être franchie avec un nouveau record
quotidien
vingt mille soldats seront mobilisés pas
seulement pour construire des hôpitaux
temporaire mais aussi pour faire
respecter le confinement
c'est un drone qui diffusent le message
sur cette plage du sud de la france
la ville de nice va plus loin que le
confinement
il y aura un couvre-feu bien sûr il ne
s'agit pas d'établir un couvre-feu
national sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais la crise qui couve en france c'est
celle de la pénurie de masques pour le
personnel soignant
nous avons appris que au départ de
l'épidémie la france a envoyé les
masques en chine et du coup on se
retrouve nous à une pénurie
voilà les chinois qui commence
progressivement à sortir de ces
difficultés nous ont renvoyé la
solidarité mais il ya urgence pour ceux
qui sont en première ligne
on n'a aucun moyen de protection pas de
lunettes pas de blouse de simple masque
pas de solution hydro alcoolique
donc voilà on n'a aucun moyen de se
protéger de protéger nos familles les
patients qui seront identifiés on va les
prendre en charge sans le savoir et sans
protection
aux etats unis 40 millions de
californiens sont maintenant confinés
chez eux
nous fermons laval dit de son côté le
gouverneur de new york qui met en place
le même genre de restrictions pour les
20 millions de résidents de l'état pas
question de confinement nationale pour
donald trump qui se concentre sur un
autre enjeu et fermer la frontière avec
le mexique pour des raisons sanitaires
si mathieu prost radio canada